hi i'm chef ezra sachoa today i'm going
to show you how to make amazing alba
store from start to finish
[Music]
sual pastor is a way of making tacos
it's one of the most popular tacos i
would say in mexico it's usually made
out of pork and it's layer by layer with
different kinds of spices different kind
of rubs i think a taqueria is not
complete unless you have a pastor
today we're going to make my own style
so first off we're gonna toast all these
aromatics we're gonna toast the cloves
the bay leaf the cinnamon sticks the
peppercorn under high heat rotate a
little bit mix it up a lot of the smoke
is gonna start to pop out and that's a
good sign that you're on the right track
so we're going to put these aside we're
going to torch our dried chilis in this
case we're going to use a california
dried chile we're going to use guajillo
you could deep fry these you could toast
them you could boil them in this case we
decided to go with the torch give a
little extra smoky flavor to it it's
going to start to blister a little bit
it's going to change color it's going to
start to become a little crispy and
that's a good sign that you're doing it
properly so now we're going to get all
these components mix in our vinegar our
fresh garlic our onion our canned
pineapple and this is a little twist
this is my own version of pasta tacos
we're going to use molasses it goes
perfect with this marinade so we're
getting everything together we're going
to blend it so we have a nice thick
paste
[Music]
[Music]
so our adobo paste is ready to go now
i'm going to grab my needs particularly
i love to use both shoulder and i like
to get it about a quarter inch thick not
too thick not too thin i want to be able
to control the fat to the protein ratio
i like to marinate piece by piece
because i like to keep track of every
individual heat i kind of know where the
good pieces are at the little pieces the
trimmings
so now we're going to building our trunk
i love to put a pineapple at the bottom
of the base because when i start to trim
the blade of my knife doesn't hit the
steel at the bottom building a drone
board is very labor intensive it's very
physical it's emotional it takes me
about 45 to an hour for me personally
it's very relaxing therapeutic it's
really fun it's literally like doing a
vertical puzzle to me usually we make a
tropo here mexicali taco and that's
about a 30 to 40 pounder depending on
the day out of that trophy you could
probably get about 300 to 400 tacos so
it's very important that when you're
building your tron puerto pastores that
you trim as you go so you're going to
pile it up you're going to have these
little off the edges trimmings and you
put them in the right little places
you're building your your puzzle
remember so it's very important that you
trim you pile trim pile
also the biggest reason too is that if
you were to trim everything at the end
you're gonna have a lot of leftover trim
and you can't put it inside the throttle
anymore it's too late
i love to finish it off with a piece of
pork belly on the top i scored it a
little bit to ooze out all the fatness
and all the juices out of the pork belly
it water falls down and trickles down
into the thrombo and that's super
important to keep it hydrated it's the
machine and you got to have it oiled up
and really nice
so i'm not finished with my trumpo now
i'm gonna take it to my trumpo spit my
vertical grill we're gonna place it
there and i want to pipe it hot as high
as it goes why because i want a torch i
want to sear every single layer um i
want to get a nice caramelization you
know the molasses are going to come
through they're going to melt
and it's going to create this crust
combine it with the chilies the
fattiness of the pork and then i'm going
to start shaving maybe 20 minutes after
the first year i start trimming it
giving a better shake and then from
there on it's the same process until you
finish all of your thrombo personally i
like to shave my my pastora trompo very
thin why because everybody's favorite
part is the crust the crust is the most
flavorful part so if you shave it really
thin you're gonna have more crust
component into each bite of your
stockpile it's gonna be amazing we're
gonna get a pineapple we're gonna slice
it and put it directly on the grill dust
it up with a little bit of sugar open
flame it's gonna caramelize it's gonna
give it a different flavor to it gonna
get it smokey this little syrup is gonna
come out of it and then you slice it
really thin a proper pastor taco must
have the following
corn flour tortilla beautiful thinly
sliced roasted chaat al pastor means
super important guacamole you're gonna
have onion cilantro and you gotta finish
it with that pineapple as your final
touch on your al pastor taco gonna have
sweetness to it spiciness smokiness for
the meat fattiness sourness from a
little squeeze of lime at the very end
all the components are coming together
to make a magical bite
[Music]
and that is how our pastor is made
[Music]
you